ماليزيا
وانت تحديدا بانكم حاولتم الهروب من منظمه
التعاون الاسلامي بتشكيل تجمع اخر مختلف
قاطعته منظمه التعاون الاسلامي وقاطعته
الدول العربيه اكبر الحضور فيه كان من
الاخوان المسلمين 150 شخصيه تقريبا ماذا
اردتم من هذا التجمع
ليس صحيحا اننا انسحبنا او غادرنا منظمه
التعاون الاسلامي
مازلنا اعضاء فيها لكن هذه المنظمه تضم
اكثر من 50 دوله وراينا ان قانونها المنظم
يجعلها غير قادره على العمل بسبب الخلافات
على اتخاذ القرارات لذلك رغبنا في العثور
على دول يمكنها الاتفاق وتعمل بنفس نظامنا
لقد رغبت الدول الخمس في اظهار انه بامكان
المسلمين ان يقوموا هم ايضا جيد واذا
نجحنا فان ذلك سيكون مثالا للدول المسلمه
الاخرى
نجحتم في ذلك
للاسف لم ننجح في خطتنا بسبب انه خلال
اجتماعاتنا
بصعوبات كما ان عده دول عربيه اعترضت ما
ادى لعدم مشاركه دول مثل باكستان
واندونيسيا الكبيرهتين لكن الاجتماع كان
جيدا من حيث انه كان بنيه تقديم اقتراح
لمصلحه كل الدول الاسلاميه لكن فشل حيث لم
يكن هناك تنفيذ لما تقرر خلال الاجتماع
وكانك تقول دكتور مهاتير بانه اندونيسيا
وباكستان قرارهم ليس بيدهم قرارهم منوط
بجهات اخرى منعتهم من الحضور لماذا لا
يكون قرار باكستان واندونيسيا ما تشارك
بحاله الانقسام هذه التي يعني
تاسست لها ماليزيا
ذهب لقد نجحت دول العربيه في اقناع
باكستان واندونيسيا بعدم الالتفات للفكره
ونحن لم يكن لدينا نفس الوزن او القوه
لمجابهه اي طرف راغبنا فقط بان نعقد
مؤتمرا بكيفيه هادئه فقط لكل من كانت
قادرا على الحضور ومن لم يرغب في الحضور
فالامر كان يعود له وقد ناقش الامر مع
الدول العربيه الرافضه لعقد مؤتمر
كوالالمبتي انقل لامبو بس لحد هلا احنا مش
فاهمين او لا نستطيع ان نفهم
ما الهدف من عقد هذا المؤتمر او هذا
الملتقى
مسلم كانت لقد رغبنا في اظهاري ان دول
مسلمه بامكانها ان تكون متقدمه وان تقدم
مثال جيده للحوكمه فبخمسين دوله لم يكن
الاتفاق سهلا على التوصل للاسلوب الملائم
لكن بخمس دول فقط كان يمكن تقديم الطريق
لذلك ثم توسيعه في حال النجاح بحيث تتبعه
الدول الاخرى
ايران نموذج كانت موجوده ايران هل تحكم
ايران بطريقه طبيعيه انت ترى ما الذي يحصل
في ايران الان
نحن لم نناقش ايران نقشنا فقط مثالا
الحوكمه الجيد كنا نرغب باظهار الطريق
للاخرين ولم نجبر احدا اذا رغبوا
بالالتحاق يمكنهم ذلك واذا لم يرغبوا في
الامر عائد لهم